hey everyone darvolo here and in today's
video i'm going to be going over exactly
what is going on in tokyo avengers along
with i guess my thoughts and predictions
as to why the series could have taken
such a differing direction with this
final or supposedly final season but
just before we do continue if you do
want me to continue making more videos
on the recent events throughout tokyo
avengers then let me know down in the
comment section below and try and push
this video to 2k likes if we can smash
that then i'll make a bunch more content
with the latest happenings throughout
tokyo avengers obviously now that i'm
all caught back up so i guess this is an
extremely difficult video to make but
over the past few months i think it's
been pretty safe to say that tokyo
avengers has taken a completely
different turn with a storyline it's
honestly still too early though to be
saying that the series is trashed or has
fallen off as if you look at any of the
statistics it is still constantly
selling near the top of the japanese
sales rankings each week however that
doesn't necessarily mean that it hasn't
definitely made some blunders in the
eyes of a huge majority of the western
fans so initially i really thought that
this final arc was adding an extra level
to the story that it just didn't feel
like it had before the first part of the
story had a very raw bosuzuku feel to it
which is for those unsure a japanese
youth subculture associated with
customized motorcycles pretty much just
delinquent gangs riding around on dope
bikes fighting each other causing an
absolute ruckus like literally what
tokyo avengers had going on throughout
the majority of the story now this may
have been my fault obviously for
over-expecting and the growth of the
overall world but i know i wasn't 100
alone like get this after the time skip
it initially felt like things had risen
up a level with all these new gangs now
operating like individual groups of
yakuza fighting for control throughout
japan instead of just driving around on
bikes and fighting each other they would
now be fighting each other for control
over different laundering locations jobs
from prospective rich clients or even
just parts of law enforcement and it
especially felt like that was the case
after being introduced to senju and
seeing her stuck in a meeting with
clients who wanted protection over their
business it was super compelling and it
kept adding more and more to be hyped
about like introducing the first
generation black dragon members who just
happened to be made up of the so-called
strongest people in the entire country
then giving this crazy ass new gang the
rokuhara tandai a stupidly strong boss
that seemed to know absolutely like no
bounds at all like they do just came
over from brazil and started murking
people it was absolutely fantastic of
course though we have to talk about the
initial first blunder that i didn't
actually think was that bad of a deal to
start with however with all the
developments over the recent chapters
and how the villain of the series seemed
to pay no attention to it at all hurt me
to my damn core this is of course big
brother drakken and his death at the
hands of just some complete random
fodder dude with a gun so as i said i
thought this started off somewhat
alright with draken definitely having
the most meaningful passing out of any
character throughout the series like to
us the readers that obviously is along
with takamichi and the real cortaman
members what left me really disappointed
was that simply some complete random
took out our boy like it wasn't sanzu
who's meant to be the mastermind of the
season or the leader of the
rokuharatandai
no it was some absolute random which i
guess to start with i thought was kind
of cool as it showed me that the overall
level of the danger throughout the world
was rising yet after mikey and his new
gang paid no mind to this murder and run
me like completely the wrong way like
his death was just nothing to a bunch of
his supposedly old friends although
obviously side note because this
literally only just happened but finally
coco saw the damn light and switched up
on mikey for the best boy in
your pay but it's taken him almost too
long but still like obviously finally so
of our first major conflict of the
series the battle of the three deities
which to be honest was a really like
fire battle a lot of people who were
hyped up were hyped up for obvious
reasons they were really freaking strong
and had some dope ass backstories like
benkei and makassar especially with some
of my favorite additions and they
multiplied the community's love for
shinichiro as he somehow managed to
bring these two powerhouses together the
person though that was meant to be the
strongest the absolute meanest south
turned out to be an absolute punching
bag for a mentally insane sano manjudo
like he was stronger than like everyone
else there but all this height behind a
dude and he got completely and utterly
obliterated in a matter of moments sadly
obviously the favelas didn't mean crap
against uh kanto's god it was hyper's
for mikey's side of things though
seeing his darkness evolve into this
unstoppable and physically unbeatable
force that it currently is this darkness
however is probably where the biggest
gripe from every single tokyo avengers
fan comes in like i understand expanding
the underlying plot of this story but
this time it really didn't feel like it
was needed obviously i can't say too
much because the story isn't finished
yet as i said at the beginning and as we
saw in chapter 250 there must be some
other reason for sanju getting the scars
then what senju you know obviously keeps
thinking because honestly this made me
really upset as well and get mad at me
down in the comment section below all
you like or let me know your thoughts on
this as well but the whole idea that
mikey's dark urges originated from senju
dropping and breaking the stupid concord
jet then blaming there on sanzu really
really really annoyed me like i really
hope that there is a good explanation
for how they developed from that which
waiku is going to expand more on because
at the moment it's completely and
utterly pathetic like my reasoning for
this is because mikey had his brother
get murdered by his best friend and for
the whole damn story the reason for his
dark urges starting has been there the
person he looked up to the most in life
and wanted to be like the most dying but
no all of a sudden he had developed
these urges during the time that
shinachito was alive and it's because of
a toy breaking like it's the most
childish reasoning for wanting to
actually kill people like dude i
understand your brother dying then
slowly over time you develop a bad
mentality then each time a close friend
dies and multiplies making his dark
urges even worse but right now it's got
something to do with sanzu that we don't
even know like did a four-year-old sanju
somehow kill mikey's parents like what
the actual hit drove mikey to gain these
actual urges it was like the perfect
reasoning for them though just up and
disappeared in my eyes but oh well
that's obviously my gripe personally
apart from that one large thing there i
still absolutely do love reading the
series although i prefer bingeing it
more than obviously keeping up with it
weekly as that's just how i like to do
things in general even with like anime
and stuff like everything after mitsuya
and his clothes show with that chapter
has looked more and more on the up but
that being said i'm very afraid for the
outcome of this battle that is currently
going on because as we know this was
initially meant to be the final arc yet
it's already been split into two
different arcs by the community the
three deities arc technically ended
after the first major battle as the
three deities are literally no more
they've been absorbed into different
groups and i guess exactly what is going
on now could be considered the final arc
but even still it's hard to say how much
longer the story is going to go for
precisely as it doesn't feel like
takamichi is going to come out on top in
this like current battle so i think it's
pretty obvious when you look at it what
i'm not extremely happy with throughout
the final arc
i like obviously freaking love the story
and getting into it has helped my
channel out exponentially and i you know
obviously can't thank it enough for that
yeah i think the best way to explain
what's going on right now is it's just
like the valhalla or tenjiku arc on
complete and other steroids we have our
main boy takamichi going up against a
close friend or even best friend in
mikey everyone is getting knocked out in
the most unrealistic ways like somehow
senju lost to sanzu it doesn't even make
sense to me firstly the dude's a
he literally uses a weapon
which is just like weakling crap in the
first place then he just free hits her
in the head like why was she so hyped to
just get clapped first out of the tomen
group
oh bro don't even get you started on
parchin like why does he think it's a
good idea to currently go up against
mikey right now
paw you're a teddy bear this is just not
a good idea bro
and ben kaye obviously probably isn't
knocked out but coco still somehow
managed to surprise and smack him in the
face even though he's 10 years older
than him like twice his size
what the is well ben k and we cast
also betrayed their girl senju and i'm
sitting here like in your pay just
screaming at my monitor i i don't even
know what's going on with this battle
it's actually crazy honestly for the
longest time i thought that any pay was
a traitor who helped in draken's death
but i'm just completely utterly dead
wrong he's one of the only people out
there that realizes the absolute
wackiness of the battle currently going
down anyway as i've said countless times
throughout this video i still love this
series to death and when i get annoyed
at small things or large things it's
because i really wanted to do well over
time and not be seen in a bad light like
some of the other series i hate it when
i see people going around saying it's
trash so for the majority of people
going around on twitter talking absolute
crap as per every week of their life
chill go touch some leaves and let the
author do his thing we can complain
about it when it's finished this
obviously is a terrible analogy but
you're not going to go out and eat a
half cooked steak then complain that
it's half cooked like obviously wait and
enjoy the full meal then leave a review
afterwards so yeah that doesn't always
apply but i hope you get where i'm
coming from like kind of at least if you
have enjoyed the video then do be sure
to hit that subscribe button and also
remember to try and push the video to 2k
likes so i know you're all interested in
more tokyo revenge's content and just my
thoughts on it in general but anyway for
now it's been your professional
degenerate dear vollo and i'll see you
all an 8-bit
bye